my buddy called and said hey we'd like
Jacob to be the ring bearer at the
wedding
and I was like great Jacob had always
wanted to wear tux I was just so excited
I'd never been to a wedding before this
is my big break it's my 15 minutes of
fame so I go hey man you get to be the
ring bearer and he was like can I wear
tuts and I go yeah and he goes white tux
I go sure and he goes Top Hat I go no
and on the way out of the room
he says well I guess I can't get a cane
then I was like what
what shows are you watching dude what is
going on so asking all these questions I
had to make sure that I was informed and
knew what I was doing made sure my
attire was right I just had to make sure
I was ready for like the biggest day of
my entire life we go to the wedding now
look those of you with kids know that
age that's six that's still that pure
joy age and you know when your kid is
going to be that happy that pure joy on
their face I want to be up close to see
it because you know it doesn't happen
forever you know so I'm sitting in the
Pew and I'm by the island
he comes to the church doors
and he's in his white tux and he's got
his rings in this hand
and he's walking down the aisle and with
this hand he's going like this
doing what it said in the job
description the contract I signed said
ring bear I was just playing the part
you know I was I was I was I was there
with her wow
I was ready
oh and I was like
what is the
doing
oh come here buddy come here
do it and he goes
um I'm the ring bearer I go
error it was a word
I heard ring bear like a grizzly
it wasn't my wedding I was like well
you're doing a great job keep going
thank you
let's just speaks to who my dad is
always going for the joke he knew it
wasn't embarrassing him and it was
embarrassing somebody else so he told me
to just keep going and I did for the
whole entire rest of the ceremony just
keep roaring kudos to him for committing
to the bit or it can be committing to
the bit I guess he walked around the
whole wedding guys
or the party so about a year later my
parents got married and uh I was the
ring bearer again so the first wedding I
was the ring bear the second wedding I
was the ring bearer my parents informed
me or more my mom was like hey no claws
this wedding no none of the none of the
claws you're just a ring bearer you're
bringing the wings that's it no Roars
and I was like
you got it I mean my dad probably
thought it would have been funny but you
know it's the bride's day so what she
says goes
and all in all I think it's still pretty
funny I think the ring bear uh adds a
little Flair to the wedding
um and I think I'm you know taking notes
for my for my future wedding
um but thank you guys again for tuning
in make sure you hit the like button
leave a comment subscribe and uh
notifications on of course for when we
uh for when we drop all of our new stuff
and also don't forget our hey man
podcast is out and streaming on all
platforms wherever you listen to
podcasts go check it out uh for some
more uh some more interesting stories
between my dad and I uh thank you guys
again for tuning in I hope you have a
great day